[Music]
combat talk with the king now is the end
of the year everybody's into their
festivities for the holiday season and
we have one of the nicest fights that
you can end the year with with an
up-and-coming superstar in the making
and our former superstar can you capture
that superstar status back this is tank
Davis versus yuckiest Gamboa
[Music]
for those people that don't know Yogi's
Gamboa Gamboa is a Cuban refugee who won
Olympic gold in the Olympics and he is
what you can say is a tank is actually
Gamboa 2.0 now I'm getting ahead of
myself there let's go into this how this
fight came to be why this fight is and
what's gonna happen in this fight well I
find that a PVC has tank in a bad
position tank is in the lower weight
classes where you have Bob Arum Oscar De
La Hoya and Eddie Hearn basically owns
all those fighters that's in those lower
weight classes and for tank to make any
form of money they basically have to
pull rabbits out of their hat you know
to to you know find fighters when he was
going to fight a couple of Fighters it
just didn't fall through it didn't
happen because he's not of there sable
has to generate a tremendous amount of
money in order for these two entities to
happen
so he's supposed to fight Abdo Mars and
the morrow is pulled out with injury to
his eye never to be heard from again
I don't think Abner Mara's fights I
thought having tomorrow's woody got
knocked out that fight anyway so tank
Davis was left without a fight on the
docket the year we're going through and
tank when they had a meaningful fight
that's not good for a fighter in his
prime
so the Gamboa fight happens now for
those people that don't know Gamboa
gambol is a very fast combination
fighter speedy
was power so Gamboa has power his foot
speed he has hand speed he doesn't have
head speed
pause so this is the problem that we
have with Gamboa tank
throws combinations here and there we
make it a one-two-three Gamboa would
throw seven eight ten punches different
levels of fighting so tank will sit down
on the shots little tight shots jab his
way in use the right hand to set up and
he's a southpaw so same thing with Jambo
so we have two South Poles we don't have
to worry about head clashing that's
gonna be where to switch over that poem
remove that right there
anyway so now we have a situation where
we have old versus doom can the whole
classic reach up and bring back
something to give to this fight can the
new young buck step up to extinguish the
fire of this old classic this is what we
have here we have a situation fellas we
have a fight that people might get riled
up about now I don't really think tank
to Gamboa to seriously I think the tank
was listening to all the people in his
camp because what tank did and what i i
i balashov fighters for doing and weight
classes that require you make weight
tank missed weight
[Music]
yes you see here
I knew shenanigans was up when you do
man they brought him out in the towel
I knew shenanigans was open it was
taking long game boy was on stage for a
while damn boy was already weighed in
boom let's do it he's a professional
not to say Gamboa's never miss wait
before he has but this is tanks first
fight excuse me at 135 now things are
starting to click Gamboa is comfortable
at this weight class tank is going up to
this weight class different type of
fight so tank gets on the scale and his
dead corner they knew that he was off it
gets on the scale he fell they do the
face-off and he decides to push Gamboa
that shows me two things in boxing when
you do stuff like that that shows me
here and you're nervous you're afraid
they call it whistling past the grave
like you know you're afraid good hope
nothing jumps out at me whistling past
the gradient
showing me you're nervous you keep that
inside buddy let's show Gamboa that too
now
can have training we have fights we have
how each one fights Gamboa throws
winging shots the key to beating Gamboa
is to step in and catch him at the point
of his swing like used to do Mike Tyson
see Mike Tyson fight tighter everything
from Mike Tyson was from the cheekbone
out from here out Gamboa fights out hit
it gives you a larger lane in the middle
tank placing that seen Mike Tyson tight
format not the peekaboo defense but type
high guard so for you to get to his body
you must commit Gamboa loves the body
and gambol always commits anytime
Gamboa's got knocked down is because
he's on offense he's on the attack it's
not because he was being defensive
I don't really think he has a defensive
bone in his body be honest with you it's
purely offense tanks showed that he can
box he can move but does he has the
stamina
is this fight to fight the defines tank
can gambol going there enough to
frustrate the young lion take him out
his game and remember speed equals power
kenny catch him and finish him because
he's definitely gonna throw a billion
punches if he catches tank off his demon
it won't be anything nice it won't be
anything pretty I don't expect any head
clashes I expect tank to hunt throw a
jab to offset Gamboa's speed a movement
to set down bow up to put Gamboa in
front of him so he can reach him and
then hit him getting bow his biggest
problem is his chin he's chinny his chin
just can't hold up when he gets popped
he gets popped when he fought bud
crawford he caught blood crawford with
some joint we all thought he was about
to finish but all Gamboa's biggest
problem at that point in time was
managerial problems he was managed by 50
cent that was the whole thing with him
and Mayweather and it was just a whole
mess Gamboa got lost his best years got
lost so when he was trying to come back
he fought off bud Crawford any qualms
blood CrossFit but bud is taller longer
pause more powerful and a better boxer
his bud is a savant an ambidextrous that
means he can fight southpaw Orthodox
right hand or left hand
gets in it so we have this fight here
which is a surprise for most and it's a
beautiful way to end the year and keep
the festivities going for this holiday
I think tank can catch em early it could
be four or five rounds to be honest with
you
that's how Gamboa's chin is but I had a
respect for his gold medal I'm gonna say
tank Davis is six knockout just combat
talk with the king see y'all next year
don't drink and drive be safe and always
keep that guard up
[Music]
[Music]